RONALD SMITH:  We're finishing
up a section
on storms here, and we've
talked about convective
storms. That is, air mass
thunderstorms, severe
thunderstorms--
oh, by the way, I've been
calling these things severe
thunderstorms. When you're
reading the book, notice they
have subdivided that category
into three or four smaller
categories.
You've got your squall lines and
your mesoscale convective
systems, and so on.
So just remember, again, they're
going into this in
somewhat more detail than
I did in class.
And then the third category
we had was hurricanes.
And we finished that
up last time.
But if there are any questions
on these convective storms,
this would be a time to bring
other points out.
Any questions about hurricanes
that you've thought about
since last time?
No?
OK.
Well then, the last category
that we'll be
doing is quite different.
It's the mid-latitude
frontal cyclone.
And as I mentioned in the
beginning of the section, this
gets its energy source from
a different place.
All the convective storms get
their energy from the release
of latent heat as water
vapor condenses to
form liquid or ice.
But not these.
These come from horizontal
temperature gradients.
The point is that, if you've got
cold air next to warm air,
there is potential
energy there.
Because the warm air wants to
rise, and the cold air wants
to sink and spread underneath
the warm air.
So if I were to release--
if I had a wall, for example,
separating the warm air and
the cold air, and I suddenly
remove that wall, things would
start to change.
The warm air would rise up.
The cold air would slump
and slide under.
So there is energy available
when you've got these lateral
temperature gradients.
And that is the source of energy
for frontal cyclones.
So this name is a long one,
but mid-latitude tells us
where these things form.
Frontal-- a front is
a boundary between
cold and warm air.
And, of course, this is a little
bit redundant, because
mid-latitudes is the region
where you get the strongest
contrast between cold
air to the north and
warm air to the south.
So there's a little bit
of redundancy here.
But then it's a cyclone.
It ends up being a
counterclockwise circulation
in the northern hemisphere,
just like a hurricane.
But the dynamics and the details
are really quite
different, even though they
end up with a circulation
around a low pressure center,
just like a hurricane.
They grow from a disturbance
along the polar front.
The polar front is this boundary
that goes around the
earth in mid-latitudes,
separating cold from warm air.
And when a little kink develops
in that boundary, as
I'll show you, it
then grows and
develops a frontal cyclone.
Because they occur in the belt
of westerlies, as they evolve
and grow they move from
west to east--
not always directly from west to
east, maybe at some angle.
But generally they move from
west to east. I've never--
I don't think I've ever seen
a frontal cyclone that went
backwards, that moved towards
the west as it developed.
They all move east
in some way.
And eventually-- so these storms
do have a life cycle.
They don't last forever.
They start from a little kink
in the polar front.
They grow.
And as I will show, once the
warm air has all been lifted
upwards, then the energy source
is gone, and these
storms will begin to die.
So they do have a natural
life cycle.
Typically, they last--
I don't know-- five to seven
days as they move across the
landscape from west to east.
So here's a simple
picture of one.
It's got the classic features
of the low pressure center,
the cold front, and
the warm front.
And also scattered around the
diagram are some of the
indications of some of
the types of local
weather that you get.
So I'll come back to define
these fronts in just a minute,
but first of all you've got some
rain showers along the
cold front.
In this case you've got some
freezing rain up here.
Remember what causes that.
That's that cold aloft warm and
then cold near the surface
that can supercool those
raindrops before
they hit the surface.
And you've got the light
snow here, heavy snow
back in the cold air.
So a lot of local types of
weather are going along with
this large scale storm.
Now in order to make any sense
of frontal cyclones, you have
to know the different
definitions of the fronts.
The word front by itself
simply means a boundary
between warm and cold air.
A cold front, indicated by the
filled triangles, is when the
cold air is advancing.
A warm front, indicated by the
filled half-circles, is when
the warm air is advancing.
So those little symbols are
telling you how these fronts
are moving.
The cold air is back here.
The warm air is there.
So we know, because that's
defined as a cold front, we
know that it's moving
in this direction.
This one, the warm air is here,
the cold air there.
It's a warm front,
so that means
the warm air is advancing.
It must be moving in
that direction.
So in a way, those are telling
you a little bit about motion,
how that front is moving
with time.
So thats a-- a few other
definitions--
this little sector back here
is called the warm sector.
And of course it has warm
air moving up, very
often in New Haven.
Very often that air is coming
from the Caribbean.
And behind it you've
got cold air.
And usually that's coming
down from Canada.
So you end up with a contrast
here, across the cold front
between air masses of
different sources--
Caribbean area here,
Canadian air here.
Notice also, this meets the
criteria that I laid out a day
or two ago about needing to
transport heat northwards.
So here's northward-moving
warm air,
southward-moving cold air.
Probably the same amount of air
altogether is moving, but
there's a net transport
of heat.
Because you're pushing warm
air northward and cold air
southward, there's a
net amount of heat
being carried northward.
And that helps to balance the
excess solar radiation near
the equator, and the deficit of
solar radiation and emitted
radiation near the pole.
So this plays a big role
in the general
circulation as well.
Questions so far on
frontal cyclone?
So here, now, is the
history of one.
It starts as a little dimple
in the polar front.
And already you can see
the characteristics.
The cold air begins to advance,
so we can label that
as a cold front.
The warm air begins to push
northward, so it can be
labeled as a warm front.
But it's very weak.
A day or two later it'll
look more like this.
This is a fully developed,
mature cyclone--
low pressure center, cold
front, warm front, warm
sector, cold air from behind.
Then it goes to this stage.
This is called the
early occlusion.
And the word occlusion refers to
the fact that now the cold
fronts and the warm fronts, at
least in the northern part--
not here but up here--
they're beginning to
come together.
I want to try to describe
that to you.
And the main thing you
have to recognize--
I'll try to do it here on the
table and hope you can see me.
These fronts are drawn where
they intersect the
surface of the Earth.
But they're not vertical
boundaries in the atmosphere.
They are tilted boundaries
between cold and warm air.
So for example, here's the
cold front with cold air
underneath the wedge.
Here's the warm front with cold
air underneath the wedge.
And when they come together
like this, now they're
occluding, because they
have touched at the
surface of the Earth.
I'll lift it up and pretend
the surface of
the Earth is here.
When they come together like
this, now they are occluding.
And notice that the warm air,
which was in the middle, has
been pinched off the ground.
Now the warm air is up, and
you've got cold air and cold
air that have touched
each other at the
surface of the Earth.
So that's the meaning of
the word occlusion.
It's where the cold front and
the warm front have come
together, pinching the
warm air upwards.
And that is where it
wants to be, right?
Warm air is buoyant.
It wants to be up.
So as soon as the occlusion
begins, then the energy source
to keep this storm going
begins to weaken.
This is the early occlusion.
And now we can say, cold
front, warm front, and
occluded front.
Notice the symbols
they're using.
They put the warm front and the
cold front together on the
same side of the line,
indicating that's now an
occluded front.
And here, it's occluded all
the way down to there.
And you've only got a little bit
of the original cold and
warm front.
This one, they've labeled
it late occlusion.
This storm is dying at this
point, it's weakening.
Due to friction and so on, the
energy source is gone.
Friction is acting
to decay it.
Typically, it'll take five to
seven days to go from this
stage to that stage.
And by that time, it's probably
traveled 5,000 or
10,000 kilometers from west to
east. This storm may have
begun to form east of the Rocky
Mountains, and it may
finally occlude as
it's approaching
Greenland, or even England.
So these things travel a long
distance while they are going
through this kind
of a life cycle.
Questions on that?
So this is another cartoon.
But this one shows a little bit
of that tilted structure.
So here's the map view--
north, south, east, west.
There's the cold front, the
warm front, the warm sector.
Now if I do a vertical slice of
the atmosphere here, it's
drawn at the bottom.
There's the sloping
cold front.
And where it hits the
ground is where it's
marked on this map.
There's the sloping
warm front.
And where it hits the ground
is marked on the map there.
And there are some
characteristic cloud patterns
that are connected with
these fronts.
Here--
cirrus, cirrostratus,
altostratus, nimbostratus.
Nimbo means rain, and you
see it's raining there.
And these are generally stratus
clouds out ahead of
the warm front.
The cold front-- because you're
lifting warmer air with
more moisture in it, air that's
in the warm sector,
possibly air that's come
up from the Caribbean--
you tend to get more
instability.
That's a little cumulonimbus
cloud there.
Or maybe in some cases
it's stratus--
nimbostratus and altocumulus.
But these tend to be more
unstable near the position of
the cold front.
And then cold air back here,
warm and cold again here.
But remember, because this is
a cold front-- not labeled
here-- but this is a
cold front, it's
moving in that direction.
This is a warm front, which
means it's moving in that
direction also, towards the
right in that diagram.
So if we back out now and look
at a larger piece of the
Northern Hemisphere on a typical
day, anytime between
now and next April, when
you're getting strong
temperature gradients north to
south, this is typically what
it looks like.
So, generally, you've got the
polar front wrapping all the
way around the globe in
mid-latitudes, with a fairly
strong temperature gradient
across it.
And then, at different
places it'll be
doing different things.
So on this little diagram you've
got an occluded frontal
cyclone here.
You've got a mature one here and
one that's just starting
out here, for example.
And the fronts are labeled
accordingly, cold front, warm
front, stationary front, warm
front, cold front--
cold front, warm front,
cold front, warm
front, occluded front.
So all the types of fronts are
shown in this little cartoon.
Question?
STUDENT: Is there a difference
between an occluded and a
stationary front?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, a stationary front is a
definite cold-warm contrast,
but it's not moving.
Whereas an occluded front is a
cold front and a warm front
that have come together.
Therefore, you've got cold
air on both sides.
And the warm air has
been lifted aloft.
So there is a big difference.
Notice that they are
drawn differently.
This has the symbols on opposite
sides, where here the
symbols are on the same side.
So think about that.
Maybe put a sketch in your
notebook for these four types
of fronts--
cold front warm front,
stationary front,
and occluded front.
This is kind of the language
by which we describe
mid-latitude frontal cyclones.
So this is the big weather
producer throughout the fall,
winter, and spring months
in mid-latitudes.
These things just come at
us, one after the other.
Generally they control the
cycle of weather in
mid-latitudes.
You'll have a couple
days of warm air
blowing from the South.
Some precipitation
will follow.
Then you'll have a couple days
with cold air coming
down from the North.
So imagine this whole thing
moving west to east while you
are stationary.
It's almost as if you are
moving in the other
direction--
experiencing this, and then
this, and then this--
as these things move over you.
Unfortunately they're
not periodic.
They don't happen with
great periodicity.
So it becomes rather difficult
to predict the weather.
But as you get into the cycle--
if you begin to watch
the weather every day, and
occasionally take a peek at a
weather map, you'll begin to
understand this cycle of
events that is coming at you
day after day, week after
week, throughout the cool
season of the year.
Yes?
STUDENT: How can you tell by
looking at it whether it's
mature or in the early stages?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's a little
bit deeper, I guess.
They've drawn that--
I must admit that was kind
of a judgment call.
These two don't look
so very different.
This one was occluded, though,
so I could see that this is in
the final--
These, maybe it was a judgment
call as to whether this is
more mature.
It just looked like they'd
drawn it a little
bit deeper, to me.
And as I've discussed when we
were talking about clouds,
from space these storms look
like giant commas.
Then, once you see the comma,
you can try to figure out
where those fronts are.
The cold front is probably
down here.
The center of the low pressure
is somewhere in here.
It almost has an eye
in this case.
Winds are going around
this direction.
The cold air from Canada
is coming down in here.
Warm air is blowing up there.
The warm front might be back
in here without much of an
occluded front.
Or it might actually be this--
I'm sorry, it might actually
be this, in which case this
would be occluded all
the way up there.
So I can't tell for sure from
that diagram where the warm
front and the occluded
front is.
But it might be--
I'm sure that's a cold front.
But where the occlusion takes
place I'm not exactly sure.
And the same thing over here.
This is a different case
altogether, but notice how
similar they are--
low pressure center, probably
an occluded front
through here somewhere.
And then these fronts
will split apart.
You'll have the warm front
and the cold front.
The cold air, when it comes
down from Canada--
notice how clear the sky is--
when it comes over the ocean,
that will be cold air over
warm ocean.
And you'll get this
cumulus clouds
building up over the ocean.
Because you've suddenly heated
that air from below,
destabilizing the lapse rate,
causing convection, and
causing cumulus clouds
to form.
These aren't precipitating.
These are precipitating.
These are just cumulus clouds
out over the ocean.
Questions?
So these are storms, and we
need to know what they do.
To a large extent they are
beneficial because they bring
us the rain that we need.
And the snow up in the mountains
that will then melt
in the spring and summer and
give us water in the rivers.
But, on the other hand, they can
also bring damaging winds.
Especially on the--
I'll tell you where the strong
winds usually occur.
Sometimes you get strong winds
in the warm sector, but
usually the strongest winds
are back here, behind the
cyclone, coming down from the
Northwest. And of course the
rain, while it's needed, can
sometimes be very heavy.
Or the snow can be very heavy,
which can cause flooding or
deep, impenetrable
snow drifts.
Because these storms do bring
cold air down from the north,
often they can cause very severe
wind chill episodes,
with strong wind, sub-zero
temperatures, and quite
dangerous to be out in, in
this kind of a storm.
And then over the ocean, those
strong winds mentioned here,
winds passing over the ocean
generate ocean waves.
The stronger the winds,
the bigger the waves.
And they can be quite damaging
to ships at sea.
So these things have benefits
but also dangers.
I'll talk about a few of the
famous ones in just a minute.
Meteorologists like to
put names on things.
I think every field likes
to put names on things.
These are four typical storm
tracks, directions where
mid-latitude frontal cyclones
tend to move fairly
frequently.
Ones that come in off the west
coast that were generated in
the vicinity of Hawaii are
sometimes referred to
meteorologists as the
Pineapple Express.
Fun to use terms like that.
Ones that come down from Canada
are generated up in
here and then come down towards
the Midwest are often
referred to as Alberta
Clippers.
We get a lot of storms in the
west that were generated just
east of the Rocky Mountains.
We call those Rocky Mountain
Storms because
of where they generated.
But the most famous one from New
England that you may have
heard about is the Nor'easter.
How many have heard that
term Nor'easter?
All of you.
So this is just another
mid-latitude cyclone--
frontal cyclone--
but it's called a Nor'easter.
And its characteristic is that
it's normally generated in the
northern part of the Gulf of
Mexico, or more typically here
along the coast, the East Coast
of the United States.
And then it moves up to New
England from the South.
Anybody know why they're
called Nor'easters?
STUDENT: They travel
northeast?
PROFESSOR: Well, okay.
One answer is that they're
traveling northeast. But
remember, this is a
traditional term.
This term goes back 200 or 300
years before the motion of
these storms was understood
by anybody.
Right?
Wind from the northeast. So
if you are a New England
fishermen or a farmer--
especially a fisherman--
and you're fishing offshore
here, and the wind begins to
pick up from the northeast,
that is a sign
that a storm is coming.
And you would quickly head back
to a sheltered cove or
back to land to get your
ship out of the storm.
So a Nor'easter is named
Nor'easter because the first
sign of it in New England
is the development of a
northeasterly wind, an
incoming-- wind coming in from
the northeast. Now why
is that unusual?
Why would you notice that?
Well, you're in the belt
of westerlies here.
So the winds are normally coming
from west to east. So
when a wind begins to go from
the northeast, well that's a
little bit different.
And why is that a sign
of a storm to come?
Well, if a cyclone is coming
at you from the South--
remember the winds are coming
around it this way--
and so the first sign of it
you will feel as it moves
towards you is that
easterly wind.
You add a little bit of friction
into that, and it's
going to be a northeasterly
wind.
So the term Nor'easter comes
from the wind direction that
is the first indication that
this storm is approaching you.
Is that clear?
OK, Nor'easter--
frontal cyclone approaching New
England from the South,
first sign is the strengthening
wind from the
northeast. There've been
a lot of famous ones.
I've just listed a few.
There was a big blizzard in New
England in 1888 that was
the Storm of the Century type
thing that you can Google and
find out about it.
Soon after I moved to
New Haven in 1978
there was a big blizzard.
I remember we slept in our
offices because we couldn't
get home that night.
There were drifting snow.
And then recently there've been
some, not quite as strong
or as famous.
But there's been some
other Nor'easters.
And here's a typical
satellite image.
And Florida is covered here.
But generally this is the East
Coast of the United States.
And there's a big cyclone with
a cold front, the occluded
front, the warm front
back into here.
And that storm is moving up the
coast from south to north
bringing all those different
types of damages--
the winds, the heavy rains--
further up north, heavy snow,
maybe even some freezing rain
up in the Northeast. So all
these different local things
can happen.
Yes?
STUDENT: How do the winds come
from the northeast if the
frontal-- if the front is
coming from the South?
PROFESSOR: OK, lights on for a second here.
If I've got-- here's Florida,
Cape Hatteras, Cape Cod, Long
Island, New Haven.
So there's a low pressure
center here, let's say.
Above the boundary layer where
there's no friction, the
isobars are going
to be like this.
And the winds are going to be
traveling right around like
that, paralleling the isobars.
Down in the frictional boundary
layer, where the
winds aren't quite geostrophic,
there's a little
bit of a turning.
They tend to move in, still
generally going parallel to
the isobars but with
a little bit of
cross-isobar flow as well.
So here you've got some
northeasterly winds.
Now as this storm moves up in
this direction, this pattern
just translates.
And so the first thing a
fisherman up here feels is the
wind blowing from the northeast,
which is a sign
that that's--
so it's not the fronts that
I'm talking about.
It's the winds around that low
pressure center that gives
rise to the northeasterly winds
as the first sign that
this thing is approaching,
as it moves up the
coast. Does that help?
Other questions on this?
So, a lot of famous storms.
The wreck of the Edmund
Fitzgerald was a big tanker
ship in the Great Lakes.
And along came a frontal
cyclone--
you see it drawn here--
back in 1975, developed waves
so great on the Great Lakes
that this ship broke
apart and sank.
Quite a thing at the time.
Has anybody ever heard
the song about
that by Gordon Lightfoot?
Google it.
Listen to that song.
It's a great song.
It coincided with kind of the
folk music era as well.
And so this song became quite
well known, describing this
disaster but also fitting
into the genre of folk
music at the time.
So very strong frontal cyclone
generating waves
on the Great Lakes.
The blizzard of 1978--
the one I mentioned,
here in New Haven--
here's a satellite
image of it.
Now what you're seeing here,
remember, are just the cumulus
clouds as the cold air behind
the cyclone comes
out over the ocean.
But these are the fronts
back here.
And very strong winds connected
with that, and a lot
of snowfall.
And this is what the highways
look like the next morning
after the blizzard
passed away.
And then, have you heard
of The Perfect Storm?
This book by Sebastian Junger
became quite a best seller
describing a storm that hit
the Grand Banks and sank a
fisher boat, the Andrea Gail.
And here's a picture
of that storm.
And notice it looks
like the others.
You've got the cold front, the
warm front, the occluded
front, the cyclone, strong
winds, and so on, producing
big waves and sunk
that little--
So you can read about that
in Junger's book.
Now you get the same
thing in the
Southern Hemisphere, remember.
In Southern Hemisphere winter
you get a big north-south
temperature gradient.
And you get the mid-latitude
frontal cyclones.
They rotate in the opposite
direction.
Just like hurricanes rotate
oppositely in the Southern
Hemisphere, so do mid-latitude
frontal cyclones.
They are-- the winds spin
clockwise around frontal
cyclones in the Southern
Hemisphere.
And they are very strong down
there, perhaps even stronger
than in the Northern Hemisphere,
which has given
rise to these amusing terms
for these latitude belts,
which you may have heard--
the Roaring Forties, the
Furious Fifties.
And even I've heard the term
Screaming Sixties used,
referring to these latitude
belts where you get very
intense and frequent
mid-latitude frontal cyclones.
And if you're sailing on a
clipper ship 150 years ago,
out of England, trying
to reach somewhere--
First of all, remember that the
way you would do that--
the winds down here are
westerlies, just as they are
in the Northern Hemisphere
mid-latitudes.
So if you wanted to go to
Australia you'd come down here
and then go east. And then if
you wanted to return to
England you wouldn't try to
go back against these.
You'd go further east. And you'd
come this way and then
come back around.
So here we have to go around
the Cape of Good Hope.
Here you've got to go
around Cape Horn.
And especially Cape Horn is
famous for all the shipwrecks
that have occurred as ships
have tried to go around or
through this belt of very
intense and frequent
mid-latitude frontal cyclones.
So it's a very dangerous part of
the world ocean in which to
travel unless you've
got a big ship.
I've crossed that passage
a couple times.
And once or twice it's been
fairly calm, and other times
it's been anything but.
Well, that's what I was going to
say about frontal cyclones.
Again, it's not as detailed as
what the book goes into.
But are there any questions
at this
point on frontal cyclones?
Weather forecasting--
This is not a course in
weather forecasting.
You could take a whole
course in this.
But I want to say a few words
about how one forecasts all
these different types of
storms, especially the
mid-latitude frontal cyclones.
It's pretty simple but it's
a big enterprise.
The way you do it is first
describe the initial state of
the atmosphere--
that is, temperature, pressure,
wind, humidity--
everywhere, globally and
vertically, at one time.
You use weather balloons for
that, surface stations, and
satellites to get that state of
the atmosphere described.
Then you can use that as the
initial condition on a giant
integration of the equations
of motion.
These complicated equations,
which you have seen simplified
versions of in this course--
like the perfect gas law, the
hydrostatic equation, cloud
processes, and so on-- are all
programmed into these equations.
And then they're integrated
forward.
This is a huge job and usually
the largest supercomputers
that exist in the world are
dedicated to this problem.
There are a few other defense
applications that also have
some of the world's biggest
supercomputers.
But for the most part,
meteorology has led the way in
the use of the biggest computer
you could get,
because it's a giant problem to
compute forward in time the
weather processes all
around the globe.
It all has to be done
simultaneously.
In this country it's the
National Weather Service that
does all of that--
collects the data and puts them
into the equation and
runs-- puts them into the
computer and integrates those
equations forward.
And you get your forecasts
directly from the Weather
Service if you want, but then
there's a big private-sector
industry that lies
on top of that.
They get the raw results from
the computer output and then
process it to make it useful
for the consumer.
They make pretty graphics,
nice maps, predictions of
what's going to happen hour by
hour, build nice websites.
You know some of the companies
that do this.
The Weather Channel
is such a company.
There's a company called
AccuWeather that does this
sort of thing.
There's a half a dozen others.
They don't do any of this
work themselves.
So, actually, it's a pretty
sweet deal for these companies
because the government does
all the hard work.
And all they do is kind of
pretty up the forecast, make
it more useful for you and
I, and then sell it to a
television station.
Or sell it to us, or whatever,
in a nice useful form.
And then that whole process
is repeated
every 12 hours, right?
That's why those balloons
go up every 12 hours.
That's the start of the
next forecast cycle.
So that's basically the way
the forecast system works.
People are always complaining
about the--
that's one of the burdens
of being an atmospheric
scientist. You sit down
to somebody--
pick somebody on a bus and,
before you know it, they're
complaining about how bad the
weather forecasts are.
You get a little bit tired of
hearing that, because they're
actually-- for some purposes,
they're not that bad.
They're pretty good.
Now here's a diagram put out
by the National Weather
Service, so it may be
a little bit biased.
But, no, it's very
statistical.
They define a skill score.
I don't have the mathematical
form of that to give you, but
it's some kind of a measure of
the quality of the forecast--
how accurate the forecast
was, compared to
what actually happened.
And it's plotted on a
scale from 0 to 80.
But 100 would be a
perfect forecast,
perfect in all respects.
This happens to be a forecast
for the 500 millibar level.
So it's not every aspect of
the weather that's being
presented here, just the shape
of the isobaric patterns at
500 millibars.
And starts in 1955 when weather
forecasting first
began, using computers,
and goes up to
almost the present day.
Let's follow the blue curve,
which is a 36-hour forecast.
So this is the skill of
predicting the weather a day
and a half in advance--
telling the future,
if you like.
What's the weather going
to be 36 hours ahead?
The skill score was, like, 24
when I first started, and
today it's something like 78.
Again, I haven't giving you
the formula by which that
statistical measure
is derived.
But that's a pretty good
improvement over the time.
It's caused by two things,
improvements in the numerical
models and improvements in
measuring that initial state.
Both things are very
important.
You've got to measure the
initial state better, and
you've got to have a more
accurate model with higher
spatial resolution, too.
Now if you try to do a
72-hour forecast--
a three-day forecast--
of course, your skill is
going to be lower.
The further out you go in the
forecast the worse is going to
be the quality of your forecast.
But that, too, has
been improving.
So today the 72-hour forecast is
about as good as a 36-hour
forecast was in the
early '80s.
So we're definitely making
progress on this.
And of course, people are trying
to compute out still
further in time.
If you go into the Weather
Channel you'll find forecasts
out seven, eight, even
nine days in advance.
I don't usually trust those.
But they're fun to look at and
speculate about what might be.
Questions on this?
So for example, I've shown
you some of these.
This is a 500 millibar map
from a couple days ago.
It's this that they're basing
that skill score on.
Now that's a problem, because
you or I might be more
interested in whether it's
going to rain or not.
But that's not what that
particular skill score-- there
are others that measure that.
But that particular skill score
was just whether the
correct prediction was made
for the shape of those
isobaric disturbances
at 500 millibars.
So I don't mean to claim that
that measure of skill is
all-encompassing.
It just measures one aspect
of weather forecasting.
So here's my off-the-cuff
summary about how well we're
doing with various types
of storms. With severe
thunderstorms we predict the
probability pretty well.
In other words, you'll hear a
forecast saying something like
80% chance of thunderstorms
tomorrow afternoon.
We do that pretty well.
But in terms of predicting when
and where an individual
storm is going to occur, we have
almost no skill at that.
We don't know whether it's going
to occur over Hartford
or Stamford.
We just can't do that kind of
local forecasting with this
kind of storm because they're
too chaotic, they're too
random, in what triggers them.
Hurricanes-- oh and the
tornadoes which come out of
those, we're very poor at
predicting when and where a
tornado will arise.
So we use what's called
nowcasting.
It's a funny term, almost
a metaphor for failure.
But nowcasting means--
as I showed you in the film the
other day-- nowcasting is
seeing the thing and then
saying, watch out, it's there.
And also-- it's not quite that
bad, because you could see it
and see what direction
it's moving.
So you could give a few
minutes' warning to a
community where that tornado
was approaching.
But in terms of being able to
predict something like that
from a numerical model, no.
We have no skill at being able
to predict from first
principles when and where
a tornado will occur.
Moving onto hurricanes, genesis
means when you first
create the hurricane.
We're very poor at that.
Once the hurricane is formed,
we're quite good at predicting
where its track is
going to be.
For example, Hurricane Irene
was a good example of that.
They really had that track
nailed, even out three or four
days in advance.
They had a very good track
forecast. As it changes its
strength however as it moves
along its track it may weaken
or strengthen.
We're not very good at that.
So certain things we do well.
Frontal cyclones we're
pretty good at.
These wintertime storms
we often have good
skill out to five days.
Occasionally we have a real
bust. The weather service will
fail to predict the big storm
genesis event or will forecast
one that didn't occur.
But those busts are
increasingly rare.
And I'm amazed sometimes at how
skillful the prediction of
these storms can be, out even
several days in advance.
Questions there?
Now we won't finish this today,
but I want you to start
being aware of forecasts.
I usually go to this page.
You can click to it
on my website.
It's the NCAR real-time
weather data.
And for example, right
now you could--
well let's look at the upper
air data from 500 millibar
sounding for this morning.
This is the 12Z Friday
sounding.
You see the date and
time up there.
This is what the
weather's doing
right now at 500 millibars.
There's a big trough in the west
coast, a big ridge on the
east coast, and then another
cyclone moving away to the
east. This would be the
starting point for
integrations forward in time.
And then if we go back,
we can see what the
forecast is going to be.
I'll click on the forecast
tab up here.
First of all, we could look--
here's the 12-hour forecast.
So this is valid, yeah,
18 UTC Friday.
So that's going to be valid in
about three hours from now.
And there's a nicely developed
mid-latitude frontal cyclone
down here, cold front,
stationary front.
Let's go forward in time.
Let's go 36 hours in advance.
This is valid 12Z Saturday,
so this is tomorrow
morning at 8:00 AM.
You see what they're
forecasting.
The green gives you moisture
and precipitation.
The lows and the fronts
are all there.
So what about your New
Haven weekend?
It's not my job to give you an
indication of the forecast.
But anyway, it's going to be
a nice weekend, right?
We've got a high pressure
center over us.
High pressure centers
have descending air,
cleans out the clouds.
Should be very nice
for the weekend.
And let's think about
what's going to
happen after that, however.
For now I'm going to
go to an animation.
I think I want to
animate this.
Loop all times.
We'll go to something like the
500 millibar winds, and we'll
see if that's going to loop.
Why isn't that looping?
I didn't hit the loop there?
Is that what I didn't do?
OK, so these are the forecasts
now, done from the recent
balloon sounding as the
initial condition.
And you see that it's a
very well developed
trough ridge system.
And generally the whole thing
is creeping eastward.
Now this doesn't go very
far forward in time.
In fact, I don't know why.
Did I not click on the
right thing here?
Loop all times.
Yeah, well it's only giving me
a 12-hour forecast, which is
not what I want.
So let me try a different
model.
Yeah, OK.
This one goes-- this will
be a different model.
Saturday, Sunday, still good
weather over New Haven.
So remember now, this is
a computer integration.
This takes the balloon sounding
satellite data for
last Friday, for today, and then
integrates it forward in
time to get the forecast. And it
may not be accurate towards
the end of the time period, but
it's probably pretty good
for the next couple days.
We're out of time.
We'll continue this on Monday.